[Musique]
merci d'être ici et je vais essayer de
vous faire découvrir ce matériau assez
extraordinaire qu'elle en pâtit alors
tout d'abord ça fait à peu près en effet
une vingtaine d'années que j'accompagne
les organisations les équipes les
personnes aussi dans ses mouvements de
transformation permanente des
entreprises dans cette recherche d'
équilibre entre le social et
l'économique entre eux aussi l'humain et
la technique entre vie professionnelle
et vie personnelle et parce que j'ai été
témoin de la puissance de ce matériau
énergétique et que contrairement à ce
que me disent parfois mes clients je
suis ni mary poppins ni la fée clochette
je suis retourné sur les bancs de
l'université pour essayer de comprendre
ce phénomène
l'empathie qu'est-ce que l'empathie
l'empathie souvent et d'une certaine
manière utilisée comme un synonyme de
bienveillance
mais en fait c'est un peu court
là le phénomène empathique en fait si
l'on prend le mot empathie signifie
ressentir à l'intérieur de soi
ok mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'est
pas beaucoup plus avancé alors prenons
d'autres mots de la même racine
prenons par exemple antipathie ressentir
contre et là on sent bien une attitude
de fermeture
en revanche si je prends la sympathie
ressentir avec je sens alors cette
attitude d'ouverture ce lien qui
s'établit avec l'autre
l'empathie est aussi une attitude
d'ouverture c'est aussi un lien mais là
je reprendrai
expression de la psychologue américaine
lauren gbp qui dit là où la sympathie
est un mode de relation
l'empathie est un mode de connaissance
en fait l'empathie est un phénomène
complexe qui s'est développé en même
temps que notre cerveau et je dirais
même du cerveau de manière générale dans
l'évolution du vivant et jean de ses
tics et un neurobiologiste qui a
travaillé travaillé encore beaucoup sur
le sujet le décrit comme un phénomène
multidimensionnel
alors ce que je vous propose ce soir
c'est de la comparer une maison celle
que vous voyez là et on va la découvrir
ensemble si vous le voulez bien
alors cette maison elle à deux niveaux
deux étages voyons tout d'abord le
premier alors ce premier il est apparu
dans la chaîne du vivant il est apparu
au moment où les oiseaux et les
mammifères ont eu à établir un lien de
chaleur pour pouvoir se maintenir en vie
c'est à dire préserver eux mêmes leur
propre chaudière interne
c'est ce même lien de chaleur qu'ils ont
eu à mettre en place pour préserver
l'espèce c'est à dire à l'arrivée des
petits
qu'est ce que ça donne au niveau de
l'empathie et bien ça donne la contagion
des émotions je ris tuerie je pleure tu
pleures mais ça signifie aussi la
capacité à prendre soin d'un autre que
soi mais pas n'importe lequel celui de
s'aligner pour préserver l'espèce dans
les années 50 dans un grand hôpital
américain
il y avait une pouponnière et dans cette
pouponnière on accueillez les bébés nés
sous x et on avait repéré depuis
quelques temps que le taux de mortalité
de ces petits avaient augmenté
alors on a appelé un pédopsychiatre pour
essayer de comprendre ce qui se passait
lui il a trouvé en fait on avait demandé
au personnel de santé de gagner du temps
ce qui est assez classique dans notre
monde et pour gagner du temps en fait
les infirmières prenez un biberon dans
chaque main se mettait au milieu deux
berceaux et donner à boire en même temps
à deux enfants
à partir du moment où on a remis en
place bon vieux rituel qui consiste à
prendre un bébé dans ses bras pour lui
donner à boire
le taux de mortalité est redevenu dans
la moyenne qui était précédemment
ce lien de chaleur est un lien du vivant
et donc qu'est-ce que j'ai mis dans ma
maison empathique et bien j'y ai mis une
cuisine pour prendre des repas ensemble
pour partager et j'y ai mis aussi un
espace chaleureux avec des fauteuils et
puis un feu de cheminée
on pourrait même imaginer un rocking
chair on pourrait verser db voilà pour
notre premier étage
le premier niveau de la maison voyons
maintenant le second ce second étage il
est arrivé en fait au moment dans le
développement du cortex ou un sillon
bien particulier qui est le sillon
temporal supérieur s'est mis en place
et là c'est en fait la capacité à sortir
de soi qui est arrivé dans le cortex et
ce sillon le partage nous humains avec
les grands singes c'est à dire les
orangs outans les bonobos les chimpanzés
et par cette capacité là qu'est ce
qu'est devenu l'empathie et bien
l'empathie est devenu aussi cette
capacité à se mettre à la place de
l'autre pour ressentir ce qu'il ressent
et là on ouvre des nouveaux champs on
peut regarder plus loin
on peut utiliser d'autres capacités de
cerveaux que la nôtre on peut se mettre
à la place d'un autre
et là on développe la créativité et
l'imaginaire il faut que je vous raconte
l'histoire de cette prof de maths
un matin elle arrive dans sa classe elle
ne parvenait pas à faire passer un
théorème
après plusieurs essais en vingt qu'est
ce qu'elle fait elle va chercher un
élève de la classe de la veille qui
était de même niveau et qu'ils avaient
compris et elle lui dit ben vient
expliquer à tes copains là parce que moi
je n'y arrive pas et lui il a fait ça a
marché
en fait cette prof de maths elle avait
une maison empathique dans laquelle ça
circulait pas mal tant le lien de
chaleur que le lien de lumière le lien
de connaissances pourquoi parce qu'elle
s'était mise à la place de ses élèves
qu'elle avait compris qu'elle n'y
arriverait pas ce matin là et donc elle
avait su trouver la solution elle était
allée chercher un autre pour l'expliquer
mais pas n'importe quelle autre elle
était allée chercher un de ses élèves
c'est à dire qu'elle avait suffisamment
de reconnaissance ce lien de chaleur
vis-à-vis de ses élèves pour laisser la
place de sachant qui était la sienne à à
cet enfant et ça c'est assez
extraordinaire
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai mis dans ce
deuxième étage on va trouver bien
évidemment un bureau pour apprendre avec
des livres mais pas que on va y trouver
aussi une salle de jeux c'est dans cette
feuille de jeu que les enfants vont
apprendre à être en étant d'autres en
jouant cow boys et aux indiens mais
aussi on pourra y mettre des jeux vidéo
où on pourra apprendre à être le
meilleur pilote de course automobile
conduire des trucs pas possibles
on pourra même aussi et même plus grands
d'ailleurs y construire des mondes
merveilleux
voilà donc pour notre deuxième niveau de
notre maison empathique
il ya deux endroits
il ya deux éléments je ne vous ai pas
parlé celui des fondations dont je vais
vous parler tout de suite
et puis on parlera tout à l'heure de la
toiture souvent on se demande mais
finalement à partir de ce que on vient
d'expliquer tout le monde devrait être
empathique
alors pourquoi ne sommes nous pas tous
or et bien nos fondations justement ces
fondations en fait elles sont
constituées de deux ingrédients
le premier sous son nouveau gène et
chacun a des gènes différents
le second c'est notre histoire et cette
histoire est elle aussi singulière elle
nous appartient à chacun avec ses bons
et ses moins bonnes nouvelles
[Applaudissements]
c'est cette histoire surtout qui a un
début et le début notre histoire
et bien c'est le moment où on est
accueilli au monde
c'est notre venue au monde et on n'est
pas forcément tous accueillis de la même
façon en fait un animal lui il se pose
pas de questions quand son petit arrive
qu'est-ce qui fait il établit d'emblée
un lien de chaleur mais nous parents
dont je suis
puis en a sûrement d'autres ici ce soir
qu'est ce qu'on fait on se pose des
questions on se dit mais comment je peux
être un bon parent et là on va chercher
la formule magique qui d'ailleurs
n'existe toujours pas et c'est comme ça
que parfois ça peut être un peu plus
compliqué alors voilà bah forcément on
n'habite pas notre maison de la même
manière il ya certaines pièces qui sont
peu habitées il y en a d'autres qui sont
en travaux
il ya parfois aussi des personnes qui
restent coincés au deuxième étage celui
de la lumière mais qui oublie de
redescendre au premier celui de la
chaleur on n'accueille pas non plus les
autres de la même façon certains les
maisons grande ouverte
parfois trop d'autres au contraire sont
fermées et le lien de chaleur comme le
lien de lumière ont du mal à passer
et puis des maisons qui ressemblent à
des tour de pise
alors ces maisons là elles ont des
fondations et un premier étage un peu
fragile ce qui fait que la personne elle
est capable de se mettre à la place d'un
autre
mais pour le manipuler pas pour
construire avec elle il aider à grandir
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai mis dans ses
fondations
eh bien j'y ai mis une cave dans lequel
finalement s'entassent les traces de
notre histoire
et puis j ai mis aussi une buanderie
dans laquelle là on va trouver le linge
mais le linge qu'on pourra l'avait qu'on
pourra réparer qu'on pourra recoudre
tout comme d'ailleurs dans la cave à
côté on pourra aussi ranger trier et
pourquoi pas jeter voilà pour nos
fondations
on voit donc on a la possibilité
peut-être de mieux habiter sa maison on
a aussi peut-être la possibilité de
mieux accompagner la conduite des
travaux de nos enfants sur cette maison
empathique
il faut maintenant je vous parle de la
toiture
alors cette toiture et les là pour nous
protéger et cette toiture
on le sent bien au premier étage de
notre maison c'est le lien du vivant
c'est la préservation de l'espace donc
l'empathie elle est là présente à vous
cette protection qui est la toiture ok
mais on a quand même tout intérêt si
l'on veut développer et renforcer cette
maison à faire ainsi reculé tant le lien
de chaleur que le lien de lumière et le
lien de lumière peut lui aussi
développer la toiture il y a une
expérience tout à fait intéressante qui
a été menée de 2011 à 2014 par une
linguiste céline alvarez qui s'est
associé à une neuroscientifique et 7
neuroscientifiques ont à elles deux
elles ont mis en place un programme
éducatif qu'elles ont élaboré et testé
auprès de d'une maternelle dans une
maternelle
ce programme étant basés et suivant le
développement du cerveau de l'enfant
ce programme s'est passé dans une zone
prioritaire du côté de gennevilliers de
2011 à 2014 et ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que non seulement ce
programme accompagner le développement
du cerveau de l'enfant et améliorer les
capacités cognitives mais en plus la
maison empathique se construisait en
même temps et à partir de là on avait
des enfants qui apprenaient à canaliser
leurs émotions
on avait des enfants qui établissent et
avec l'autre une relation plus fluide
moins violente et la voilà la partie qui
permet de renforcer la toiture on a tout
intérêt à développer cette maison
empathique à en comprendre le
fonctionnement
et surtout à y faire circuler tant le
lien de chaleur qui est le lien de
reconnaissance de l'autre mais aussi ce
lien de lumière ce lien de la
connaissance
nous entrons aujourd'hui dans un monde
de transformation important le
transhumanisme fait peur il inquiète
sauf que on n'a pas attendu le
transhumanisme pour vouloir grandir
porter des lunettes pour voir plus loin
créer des vaccins pour être plus fort et
donc à partir de là on a bien eu à
mettre en place ce travail de
renforcement de notre toiture et ce
renforcement on peut le faire à
plusieurs endroits voyez bill gates avec
sa fondation aujourd'hui eh bien il
développe des vaccins pour lutter contre
le paludisme
mais on peut encore développer autrement
et il faut surtout entendre les signaux
faibles des deux îles en jeu il donne
musk pardon qui dit ok lui qui est
patron de tesla et qui développe
l'intelligence artificielle peut-être
faudrait-il mettre des barrières
éthiques
ok mais comment pensons
si l'on regarde notre maison empathique
qu'est-ce que l'empathie artificiel
l'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
elle nous dépasse à deux endroits
elle est capable de stocker beaucoup
plus de données
elle est capable aussi de calculer
beaucoup plus vite que nous mais si on
la regarde par rapport à l'empathie
artificielle qu'elle développe forcément
on s'aperçoit finalement que c'est une
empathie tronquée parce qu'elle n'a ni
fondation elle n'a ni gêne ni histoire
et elle n'a donc pas deux premiers
étages puisque lé l'empathie d'une
machine elle a pas besoin de chaleur
elle n'est pas vivante
il faut que je termine avec une une
histoire peut-être dont vous avez
entendu parler
on a un un nous un joueur de go qui qui
a voulu battre en tous les cas qui s'est
opposé à alpha go lycée dole il a perdu
quatre fois mais la cinquième fois il a
gagné
on sait pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'ils se reconnecter à sa maison
empathique
c'est à dire qu'est ce qui s'est passé
les quatre premières fois il est resté
au deuxième étage sauf que deuxième
étage
alpha go était plus fort
en revanche la 4e à la fin de la
quatrième fois il s'est dit mais c'est
pas vrai et il a eu la trouille
et là il a voulu préserver l'espèce et
il s'est dit non non non non ça sera pas
la machine ce sera moi et la gagner
parce qu'il a remis en branle tout le
système et l'a trouvé la solution qui
elle était nouvelle et qui elle n'était
pas dans l'empathie artificielle dans la
machine alors je vous invite ce soir en
rentrant chez vous à vous reconnecter à
votre premier niveau de la maison
empathique
peut-être que il y as autour de vous
quelqu'un qui vous est cher quelqu'un
avec qui vous vous êtes peut-être
brouiller ou avec lesquels vous
n'arrivez pas à passer un message et je
vous invite à le regarder vraiment elle
prendre dans vos bras et vous sentirez
ce lien de chaleur du premier étage vous
sentirez aussi la puissance de l'instant
mais ça c'est une autre histoire que je
vous raconterai peut-être une autre fois
merci à vous